okay [ __ ] picture boy psychobabble
will [ __ ] back we're doin a chapter
seven I very much the stock don't
twisting copters on the industry so if
you're people can enjoy this and I think
I'd if you guys are done I'm male that I
cried if you could just actually just
send the money you know just put it in
an envelope just cash it William I could
use your help come over here for a
second what a whopper my I found some
interesting leads this parchment
describes a way to create a type of
super concrete this is what the Nazis
have used to build all these concrete
astra [ __ ] eyes it really forget
about everything even this place this is
the only concrete they use this is how
they created all those those cities so
quickly now that we know where it comes
from I need a sample of it for closer
study just take it on the wall I'm here
for a piece of exposed concrete that
shows an outbreak of mold it should be
porous enough for you to cut me a sample
whatever you need also there was this
encrypted list of that you should member
that they shouldn't our I was at Macomb
high school compared with the official
German state records on Jewish citizens
in the years back and 39 in 1945 let me
say you received those records I know
you're beautiful but you're asking for a
lot now okay I just have one more thing
Oh like [ __ ] it's quite critical what Oh
God God okay okay
why apply light I will apply it wo we
can go now okay it's guys how you doing
okay you just I got haha [ __ ] Jim likes
he's livid what is that he lives like a
hunk of American Muscle smarts up I
guess okay where's your mold [ __ ] you
looked at them all mold inspector here
this is art is animals oh sorry it's
just a yeast infection I guess fine k
what
eep-eep yes stupid that's what she'd go
with that so [ __ ] made in that area
did he have keys you [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok purgatory where are you
wait this is a south side to the hangar
entrance
okay we're six fold mold all right here
now am I going in lights a completely
wrong area I want to stay out of there
yeah hello is we should do something
like these Lakes lady like I'm pretty
sure it's coming from that pipe I'm just
going to guess okay I'm pretty sure it's
these pipes right here okay Fargo said
where are you
that is the most force coming from the
Fed okay and tag he's breathing in it a
better temper Bolton honestly I need the
keys to the archives you got him just
looking pretty [ __ ] 30 skinny doc okay
first hold in old blaskowitz almost
longer I can keep doing that we'll be
all right we can still get the job done
I thought oh man
hi say yeah what's this about Fergus
don't know nothing everything it's about
that boy goddammit private Wyatt oh yeah
we took his eyes out they don't you
should be instead of me it was young he
had potential it could have given us a
future you and me were too [ __ ]
mommies from the past running on nothing
but we'll pose and made the wrong choice
all that's [ __ ] obvious isn't it I
was ready to die I would have done it
gladly my ass off to save that boy
blaskowitz and you [ __ ] piss it away
on a whim remember Prendergast
kid he could endure anything now he's
gone it all [ __ ] god just stop with
this useless [ __ ] skeleton
let me tell me what's a long-term
solution yeah who's gonna take over when
we're too dumb [ __ ] i strap on the
holsters anymore
alright let's use an audience oh my kids
I guess Wow
so you're just save you from prison guy
like okay alright shadow with
overspending me thinking yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'll swim in your shadow
okay I got the state records okay now I
got to work on this [ __ ] mold then
take let me just check upstairs wait
where's it coming from
maybe these parts yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is this the air intake must be from
a ceiling right okay keep going up what
is this mold infestation the fact that I
see this festering
old invasion pestering the massive
underground ventilation system okay now
where does
detergent and like to keep this area
clean [ __ ] to see like a blue link up
s where's the mall what is this [ __ ]
nice oh [ __ ] we don't
okay I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] MA where's
the mold
Cemil over there holy [ __ ] that's like
the original of [ __ ] [ __ ] nightmare
what the [ __ ] is that mean
holy [ __ ] okay yeah [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ]
top-1 [ __ ] what shorter we come from
this - I'll take this thank you very
much
stupid [ __ ] you thought you could mess
with the best and as I like the rest
well joke's on you [ __ ] Nazis [ __ ]
Nazis
okay is this like a famous store
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is that oh is that a don't
eat you up [ __ ] scary [ __ ] what this
is
hello I'm just trying to do a scape cast
castle wolfenstein [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
no Maps no
[ __ ] it I thank God Michael Delta store
should be out it was so fast candles
nothing yeah that's cool how it like
rotates always tasty it sweet funny okay
there we go oh [ __ ] he's the way to aj1
that [ __ ] app app check ahead wait how
do we get out of here they're like a
[ __ ] oh it's just like random
here--like what is this stair [ __ ]
math what is this
I don't know where the [ __ ] where God
the [ __ ] is this okay that's what you
get [ __ ] okay I went that way there's
all this [ __ ] yeah okay charge my baby
okay I guess we wanted for a while to
push huge Cap'n Castle off inside for
sure okay
come on oh that must be the exit that
the exit get me the [ __ ] out of here I
did it that's weird it's your health bar
here okay I'll talk a waste of time Oh
[ __ ] I feel like I should open that
alright well then shut up here I guess
shoots over here so can't go over there
what's this okay where's the load coming
from that's what I need to know what is
that
[ __ ] all here is like Cyrus whatever so
I feel [ __ ] sleep in this place
okay I guess I'm checked like video
which everywhere and that's the main
entrance
this is the [ __ ] interrogation room
where's the Volkov publish what I need
to know why don't lay be allowed it here
I feel like she's kind of like a risk
okay I guess I better check the hangar
again if someone could fix at allowed
the rain problems here we good
okay chase a mole detector here just a
general gold inspector here don't mind
me just making sure your mold is on that
control glasses over there a beverage
nauseated dying I'm sick is Colin
Alice's glass on our floor selenium
big Hoss
yes that's how that all era that's
irresponsible being a circular saw it on
a sample that they some power tools
nearby and I'm I'm a spot [ __ ] a
what's down here
all right again they're beaten Hogan
shut
okay last [ __ ] here
what's this way [ __ ] is that full
automatic shut thank God I thought this
over no I was just lying around but okay
okay
[ __ ]
but I like a name on this
yeah maybe so
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] down there
okay and we already think [ __ ] I'm out
close it close that at a closed guard I
think she's going to come in here start
shooting up the place
Oh legs get out ow
[Music]
kliklak innovation event is and yeah and
yes that's the best one right
chat
let's give God I guess hmm very funny
[Music]
are you doing science project you're
scaring Mac sorry girl you know it slip
out like that
hey Lizzie oh nice it has had no no kind
of I don't know so not as hurt used to
be Klaus had a son born during the war a
miracle he called it he had tried for
years to have a child him or his wife
you know he makes pretty good father for
nothing the child was born with a club
foot past knew of course what that meant
he begged the doctors not reported to
the authorities the secret police showed
up to take the boy obey Klaus and his
wife tried to stop them survived died
from a bullet to the head the child to
Klaus could not protect him so he blames
himself
everyone answered my four keys all right
let me give the other sample maybe chair
come on man
see if he's okay [ __ ] is that
that guy was max am i doing over here
I'm [ __ ] wasting time there we go
okay at night I'm going to mention that
I'm sure you guys know how about dick
laughs ok max max is good
many counties you told us towards max
find Max's toys [ __ ] that's not how I'm
going to find them that's too much of a
task a bunch of toys but okay what do I
have a firetruck fun cue the [ __ ] t/a
got all the a quite a beer
hello I'm looking for an a let's give
them some knives instead you know
okay well I can't file I'm sorry max a
shot glass there's numberless check out
downstairs ha toy boy come online
whatsapp icon box of matches
oh I'm missing a lot of [ __ ] some
automatics I'll get you all ok wait no
all I need is a fire truck now okay oh
oh I say this only shoots real quick
miss our fire truck where are you
I like it for you oh I found it
okay very much yeah
no wrong room [ __ ] in a room where you
[Music]
[Music]
okay it was worth it but I did it all
right I think you should we have a
mission right
yeah exit level Thank You William
sometimes I thought those toys on to
something until gum it's good Jenny man
I'm good thanks to their concrete the
essential building material of the right
is based on the dotty issue technology
it's almost perfect but it's
deteriorating through time developing
mold
someone is tampering with and makes
someone who knows its secrets I analyzed
it and found a trace of this type of
limestone that exists only in northern
Croatia now look at this name set rust
it appears three times in dot issues I
totally know what the [ __ ] body
should mean to official record systems
attained in 1941 in wood and kind of to
a forced labor camp invented in northern
Asia now this is where things get
interesting the labor jerk saves
Barnstone from a query for manufacture
of the concrete I believe this is the
place where we'll find a trois
living member of that Egypt problem is
there's so many unknowns a lot of words
and chances are he's dead already
we can't assault a sin to this magnitude
and hope to locate you before the whole
damn not the army arrived what is the
plan
someone needs to go in there inside you
go undercover fast in a prison again not
Hank yeah your antics was this lost
culture ah sorry I didn't volunteer so
stupid I was arrogant I want to Center
Mary for Santa -
let's sit at that [ __ ]
[Music]
okay we're gonna add this here thank
y'all for watching